the Joe Rogan experience shut my phone
up I can show you I found this picture
on Instagram of this tiger and the
[ __ ] thing is what looked like its
legs but it looks like it's doing dips
the list of [ __ ] muscles it doesn't
even look real like like like that thing
exists on this planet and was just like
was just walking around free that you
could just bump into it I understand you
know like when people first came out
here and they eradicated that's along
the lines of it I mean look at that how
many pull-ups Joe do you need to do to
[ __ ] look like that [ __ ] oh my God
look at the [ __ ] muscles you must
have seen that one do you ever see that
one where they were [ __ ] with that
tiger and that dude was on the elephant
yeah and this thing took off like Jordan
in the dunking contest and just and
every time he did it reached its apex it
kept going up like [ __ ] Zion there on
Duke yeah and it barely grazed the guy's
arm when it clawed him toward park yeah
yeah the guy like he had nerve damage
and his [ __ ] arm didn't work oh yeah
for sure yeah I mean there's a great
video recent video like two weeks ago of
these guys on a motorcycle in India and
the riders chasing them and the tiger
almost get some it's full clip chasing I
actually looked how fast they can run
and I'm surprised because the guy was on
like a scooter or something they can go
like 40 miles an hour I think what
[ __ ] him up was this surface that he
started out riding on right if he was
more in his element they get like a dog
in a kitchen gets a little [ __ ] on
the concrete right yeah yeah well maybe
just the sound of the engine was just
like that doesn't sound tasty well it's
one of the where rare places on earth
where Tigers hunt people there's there's
a history of them hunting people they
hunt or they come upon another alley
you know they hunt them there's an area
called the Sunderbans and the Sunderbans
Tigers over the last 200 years have
killed more than 300,000 people there
they actively you know people believe it
or not it's a quick death oh yeah I
already know what I would ever do if I
ever came in contact with the tiger just
do this that's exactly what I would do
given the neck
[Laughter]
and make some defensive move like our
offensive moves just to get it go right
towards it
oh there's just like the you UFC guys
are all like I would rather get [ __ ]
choked out then knocked out it's the
same thing you just go to sleep
yeah you just sleep I mean it probably
hurts for a second and then it's over oh
this hurts for a second then as you
start to go I think the last thing
that's as bad as the smell of the tiger
all the breath the breath big day me
rotten meat breath oh just affect you
know they don't really bathe do I swim
don't they delegate swim fast this is
how fast you smell amazing did you see
those two poor women who they were gonna
take a [ __ ] hike through the
rainforest and decided to go themselves
gone what happened they found their
clothes where was this
which rainforest yeah I don't know so
that was right in your app right up your
[ __ ] alley isn't - I was surprised it
wasn't on your Instagram like that's
that's like that's a Rogen [ __ ] right
there that's a bummer man people get
confused and they don't understand you
you're a moving thing and you don't move
quick and they're they're all about
eating moving things if you're moving
they're trying to eat you if you if
you're by yourself they're gonna eat
well it's amazing that wherever we
started on this planet that our brain
was able to cover for the fact of how
[ __ ] slow we are we're slower than
squirrels like everything everything is
lightning fast out there except sloths
sloths I know but they like and that but
that's their job to get eaten yeah yeah
like jalapeno poppers that [ __ ] that
you just order you want to go say [ __ ]
let's get that slop yeah yeah this is
what you go after the real thing you're
trying to eat one of my favorite videos
is watching harpy eagles kill sloths
they swoop in and snatch them they're
like the largest Eagles in South America
she did a zipline tour in and Coster I
did that yeah and the guy knew how to
make the noise of the this this [ __ ]
ridiculous wingspan bird that
it really exists in that area anymore
but they just in their DNA for them to
freak out he goes it's three toed sloth
and he imitated it and the [ __ ] thing
just just kind of looked around a little
bit it's like dude you just gave that
thing a mini [ __ ] heart attack we did
a zipline that was one mile you get on
it you you zip across for one mile as
I'm sliding on this thing with my family
by the way I'm thinking one last thing
they check this who's checking this huh
those are great thoughts the [ __ ]
ladder was rusted and then lat ratchet
bolted so they had like straps were they
ratcheted where the ladder had rusted
and then they just grabbed a hold of
strap and like clamped down on it to the
[ __ ] tree and we're climbing up this
and it's like a little watch out there
that parts rusted through like what
that's rusted through and then you get
to the top and they latch you up to this
thing and I'm telling you you're above
the rain forest and it's just yeah and
you go for like [ __ ] 10 minutes just
how high those two we were just in the
[ __ ] we were just in the very
tippity-top up we've been Costa Rica so
we weren't like in the [ __ ] and I just
remember like the thing where we were
doing you know the little I guess
platform that you went up to was so
[ __ ] high off the ground and it was a
third up to tree yeah like when we were
looking up at the three-toed sloth that
was over there it was like another four
five hundred feet it seemed it was
ridiculous [ __ ] ridiculous
you know nature man nature man there's a
[ __ ] great story recently of a guy
he's a musician and he was recording
sounds of nature and he fell asleep and
a bear ate him
so it's recording of him getting eaten
while he's recording sounds of danger
bears seem like it's a long death oh
yeah they just eat you they just hold
you down like a salmon and start chewing
chunks oh oh yeah they do yeah that cuz
they're omnivores omnivores of the worst
thing to get killed by you better off
getting killed by a predator because
predators generally just want to kill
you and kill you as quick as they can
but bears first of all there are no
predators other than other bears and
humans with rifles and if they're in a
place where there's no humans with
rifles to the top of the food chain so
just put a paw down on you so they hold
you in place and just start chewing
chunks of you just eating chunks of you
off the video the grizzle see my special
tonight at midnight on Netflix do you
know what my brother called me up one
time I I called him after he had watched
some video and it was one of those
Komodo dragons and it somehow grabbed
like a deer looking thing whatever the
[ __ ] is in its world that's like that
and it I'm sorry people but it snapped
its [ __ ] leg and he said the thing
was laying there and it couldn't move
and it would just started eating the
things guts and the deers sound of I
don't watch any of that I don't want
execution videos I don't want that on my
harddrive
mmm I'm gonna bomb tonight watching that
how do you find it that quick Jesus
Christ this guy's good he's got him
saved yeah there's a great one of a
komodo dragon eating a monkey and it's
got like look at it might be a baboon
it's a baboons are no joke I never knew
when they [ __ ] yawn you like oh [ __ ]
that's like a tiger monkey it's like a
dog monkey that's what it's like it's
like I got to Jose Fang wolf Raisa wolf
monkey no
hey kids somebody's got a new band name
that wolf monkey monkey that's good
there's a great video of this komodo
dragon he's got this monkey's feet and
tail hanging out of his mouth he's doing
just slowly choking this thing down
eating this entire monkey whole loop and
the tail and a little whole feet are
poking out
see if you can find that show it the
bill no I don't want to I see don't want
to unclear on that one so I don't I
don't want to you
[Applause]